Let's do a quick exercise to demonstrate
the states of a media player.
But you're going to be playing
the part of the media player.
So sit down for a moment and
wait for my first instruction.
Now think of a song in your head and
prepare to sing it.
All right.
Now start singing it aloud.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And pause.
Now I'd like you to resume
where you left off.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And now stop!
And completely forget that song.
Now I want you to think of
an entirely different song but
don't sing aloud just yet.
Alright, start singing it now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And stop great job.
Take a moment, sit back and relax.
So why did I make you sing.
Well to help explain this concept.
So playing the audio files
within the MediaPlayer class
is managed via a state machine.
And this means that there are different
states that we can transition between
as the media player plays a song.
So we can draw a diagram known
as a state machine diagram
to help visualize the different
states the media player can be.
So first off is idle state, which means
that the media player object is just
sitting there Idle,
not making any sound.
And this is just like how you were idle,
sitting there waiting for
my instructions.
Following that is the prepared state,
meaning that the media player
is preparing to play a certain
audio file like a song.
And this is just like how you
were thinking about a song and
preparing to sing it, but
didn't make any sound just yet.
And then comes the Started state,
meaning that the media player is playing
a certain audio file like our song.
So this is similar to when you
started to sing the song aloud.
>> Row, row, row your boat,
gently down the stream.
And then comes the pause state
when you want to pause the song.
And this is like when
you pause your singing.
Now from the Paused state you can
move back to the Started state.
If you want to resume
the song where you left off
[MUSIC].
Now any time you can
stop singing the song,
meaning that the media
player is in its stop state.
Now there's one catch.
Once you stop the media player,
you can't resume it again.
You need to set it up to prepare to
sing it again by specifying which song
you want to play.
So either the same or a different song.
And that's why I had you think of
a different song and prepare to sing it.
And then I had you sing the new song,
moving us back to the started set again.
>> ABCDEFG
>> As you can see, there are a number of
different states to the media player
>> Use the control how audio is played
back to the user.
And again this is referred to
as a state machine diagram.
We actually presented a simplified
version of the MediaPlayer life cycle
in order to help you understand
the big picture first.
Now the official documentation
page contains the complete
state machine diagram.
Which usually virtue in the future, so
at first I know we can
all a very overwhelming.
But notice that the diagram has to say,
so we talked about, so idle, prepared,
started, paused, stopped,
and a couple other ones.
Know that it also provides details
on what media play methods
we can call in order to
transition between these states.
So feel free to take a look at
the state diagram on your own and
we've linked it below in the notes.